EDITION COLLECTION.
THIS IS GAME SEVEN OF THE
EASTERN CONFERENCE SEMIFINAL
SERIES.
AND THE SCREEN -- AND LOOK OUT!
DURANT WAS HIT HARD BY P.J.
TUCKER.
DURANT WAS LEAPING FOR THAT
REBOUND.
>> Grant: THAT IS FOUR FOULS ON
P.J. TUCKER, WHICH OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING TO KEEP AN EYE ON, BUT
AS THEY ARE GOING FOR THE BALL
THERE, AND TUCKER RAN RIGHT INTO
DURANT, AND COLLIDED AND THE
SECOND COLLISION THAT DURANT HAS
HAD HERE IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR TUCKER,
THAT IS FOUR FOULS AS I SAID,
AND THE MATCHUP WITH DURANT IS
SO IMPORTANT DEFENSIVELY FOR THE
BUCKS.
>> Marv: THE BUCKS ARE OVER THE
FOUL LIMIT.
KEVIN DURANT IS 3 OF 4 AT THE
LINE.
THAT IS POINT NUMBER 28.
>> Grant: IT LOOKED LIKE RIGHT
THERE THAT KEVIN DURANT'S MOM IS
TALKING TO P.J. TUCKER.
>> Marv: THAT IS WANDA SITTING
COURTSIDE.
CAN'T READ LIPS BECAUSE THE MASK
IS ON.
>> Grant: I AM SURE IT IS ALL
FRIENDLY.
>> Marv: REALLY?
>> Grant: WELL, THEY ARE
FRIENDS, AND THEY GE